hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play de gracia
phobia digression phobia alright so
obviously I was supposed to toss this
stuff over so maybe there's something
over here and like the adjacent room to
the tunnel that I'm supposed to drill
through or maybe I'm not exactly sure I
I am I'm kind of at a loss for this one
maybe I should have like I like to try
to find the exit for just start it up
again I don't know I don't know but
obviously I'm supposed to do this here
can I use that item this way ok so
obviously I'm not supposed to use it on
a door hinges maybe no there's a clever
way of thinking old Simon buddy but yeah
might as well kill yourself ok god damn
it Simon why you gotta be so stupid why
I gotta be so stupid
Simon bigger head out your ass you're
probably the same psychopath from cry
fear aren't you gotta hold your hand
hold on oh oh oh come on
that would have been genius I thought I
had a total brain wave right there for
some reason I can't get this to open so
I was thinking maybe oh that would have
been great dick in fact sassafras all
right there was nothing in here right
not that I could see anyway so friggin
you are oh you don't feel sleepy right
now
yes sleepy why is that there anyway why
can't work in it why can i click that
why why can i click that
like why is that a usable thing what is
that clothes come behind you huh wha
okay screw you guys I can't even take
your heads
you destroyed my one weapon against you
oh okay I'll go back down I might have
been I that have been a bit too eager to
get out of there so let's see if there's
like one more item that I needed didn't
I get a key oh no wait I use the key
never mind back down here I don't like
being donor
don't start the music please oh oh I
hate it more than anything I hate this I
hate this so much
I hate it Oh what was in here what was
in here what was in here was there
something in here that I need that I
need to use useful you see the uzi thing
you think it's real part back here I
remember
every time it thumps
I just go down here
check it one more time get out of here
because I do not want to be done
something blocking the door let's the
other way it doesn't look like it
doesn't look like and yes I have been
recording these sequentially so I
haven't had a chance to look at comments
if people posted on what I'm supposed to
do sorry about that I think that's
supposed to be sound like rain that sort
of machine noise over there moving the
barrel is just in case is something
you're gonna behind it I don't know
weekly key wine knock you know I'm
checking every single room again just in
case
no no no oh
what uh-oh okay so obviously ah really
does take away this stuff from mark I
did not know that okay interesting okay
so I'm definitely supposed to be over
with Simon I'm just not using the items
correctly so I will second hang on let
me double check just to be thorough just
to be thorough you double-check
everything just in case because I might
have missed something in my haste I
thought I'd look at your boxes I mean
it's really cool mechanic and all but
it's hard to tell sometimes when you've
cleared out one area and you don't need
to go back so I have cleared everything
here except the well but I'm pretty sure
there's nothing else
go back here I hate that thing so much
impossible to get past I hate that oh my
god is so bad it's so bad yeah I don't
feel sleepy right now so there's got to
be something here there just has to be
office door knock please oh man I'm just
like I'd think that the drill would be
used to try to bust down a lock or
something but no it is not obvious right
now it is definitely not obvious I don't
know what the deal is I'm sorry you guys
I'm failing so hardcore here but good we
second take you guys definitely failing
oh don't tell me what is the point of
being up here why would I need to come
up here why why would it allow me to
come up here there's got to be a reason
does that mean there's a reason for
everything even if a room seems
incompletions conspicuously usually has
items in it and this area of here has no
how turn young for a fragment this has
known noon they said noon so why I
supposed to jump to the circle of love
nope that didn't do anything except hurt
yeah yeah hers deal with it so like
these no I'm out of tinderboxes now
congratulations I just used all the
tenses like an a-hole there's gotta be
something here
don't let me flounder I don't feel
sleepy right now I will knock you in
your skull and make you sleepy you dick
if you don't figure out what the hell
you're supposed to do
another problem is it's really hard to
see anything so it's easy to miss
because if there is something that I
mean it's just practically gone in the
next second anything I've been up here
before but to no avail
no avail alright I'm okay with tough
puzzles so long as you give me some
clues this isn't a puzzle this is uh
choose-your-own-adventure or this is a
old-school adventure click everything to
everything at least once and hold good
hope for the best this enough fire floss
immortalis floss put put it in the Ring
of Hearts object I'll use it on ya can't
you just item this way No darn it
well I mean that's that's literally
everything that is quite literally
everything alright let me check the one
place that I haven't checked again which
would be the well where I got the poison
clan
all right okay all right go back down
here I said I hate it's like I know
nothing bad is gonna happen down here
but still let's get out there maybe down
there maybe maybe maybe maybe do
something something something down here
ow not that I can see unless I don't
know what was floating the sizes oh it's
a bomb lovely another poem more poems
ha ha don't get me out here
go get me out here Oh God that's like oh
god oh oh my heart's beating I could I
was so expecting yeah never mind never
mind ok I've done everything game what
do you want from me Oh give me Eddie
Oh give me out here yeah give me honey I
don't even have the drill anymore I
don't I don't I don't I don't I don't
I'm going back going back I'm going back
there's nothing for me down here there's
nothing
how about I kill myself is that gonna
help they're giving it we need to get
out of here then why did I get that
drill if I can't do anything with it you
bastard you bastard just to make sure
progress is made I'm going to we're
gonna jump into the future where I solve
this puzzle Oh No
jump cut all right
I've been running around everywhere I
know every detail of this game now I
even went into my journal and read the
notes on advanced mutation so that I
know what's gonna happen now I need a
dead body I know that there's a freakin
dead body up here because I can hear
flies and then I was like oh oh no I
just gotta get a key for that door I
wonder where that kid and up and up and
I've been down and I've been all over
the place
and I've been throwing things at this
door and I finally stepped up here and
went just give it to all youth over I
swear I have been
really yeah huh a mini chest really oh
look at that that's so adorable a piece
of paper this letter is only for those
who is has got the duty to clean up my
torture testing chamber remove corpses
from the torture tables don't touch any
tools in the room my experiments are
secret you will have to forget what you
have seen when you leave the room if you
find anybody alive leave the room and
come to my heart broken rules will be
immediately make you a voluntary test
subject J I imagine that's Justine cuz
that makes sense because alone before
said just it's Justine not juice not jus
do not is Justine so there I go there's
your progress and God man I swear I've
been running around for 45 minutes so
now I'm all out of time so thank you all
so much for watching click the links in
the annotation for more stuff that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye